tim préparatifs derniers essais à vide
bordeaux s'apprête à vivre demain son
ajouté avec un thé comme trame où après
trois ans de travaux la première des
trois lignes ouvrira dès 5h demain matin
embrasement du comte pierre multiples
animations déplacement du président de
la république
cette inauguration et pour alain juppé
un acte important car pour le maire de
bordeaux
le tramway doit changer les habitudes va
falloir prendre l'habitude de laisser sa
voiture à quelques kilomètres du centre
ville dans un parking étudié pour ça
gratuit et gardienné et de monter dans
un tramway pour arriver à aucun courant
ce place les verts la royère donc là il
ya un changement de mentalité le tramway
symbole de modernité
amusant clin d'oeil de l'histoire il y à
45 ans presque jour pour jour le maire
de l'époque jacques chaban delmas était
fier lui d'enterrer ce moyen de
transport
bordeaux et sa banlieue avaient alors
200 km de réseau mais le tramway est
considérée comme peu sûres et dépasser
devait laisser place à l'automobile
alors bien sûr aujourd'hui ce retour à
bordeaux ne laisse personne indiffé aux
formidables surtout par paulette cantat
pour cause paulette est une ancienne
halle wattman autrement dit conductrice
de tram entre émerveillement et
curiosité première visite premières
découvertes
direction le poste de pilotage
électronique caméra bouton voyant rien à
voir avec ce qu'elle avait connu dès ses
débuts en 1943 on n'avait pas en avait
que deux manettes et le une [ __ ] au
pied mais bon on n'était pas si elle
était depuis lors mon petit m 53
silencieux esthétique au delà de la
nostalgie
ce nouveau tramway a visiblement conquis
police s'y fier d'avoir conduit mélasse
c'est un beau jouet
dès demain les bordelais pourront faire
joujou en vrai avec leurs travaux